America is on the brink of a historic
moment Democrats in Washington are
beaming out what they can only hope is a
clear urgent signal the president Trump
abused his power and must be stopped
what message is actually being received
and who's listening
[Music]
there are few places where impeachment
is more contentious than Wisconsin one
of the Rust Belt states that propelled
Trump to the White House Racine County
has swung between Republicans and
Democrats for years it's a national
bellwether that last time went for Trump
you ready for Christmas really humbug a
little bit okay yeah
Wesley set up his plumbing business
eight years ago this is Jeff he runs my
remodeling better starting solo out of
his garage he now has 30 employees since
transparent office this place is taken
off really oh my god
yeah busy yeah these are all jobs that
we have booked so the Democrats say
Donald Trump abused his power he
pressured a foreign government to
interfere in a u.s. election crucially
for his own political gain you don't buy
that not at all why can't Donald Trump
have an investigation into Joe Biden
just a big dog and pony show trained up
bring doubt in the voters minds that you
got yourself a crook in there you know
and he's a crook what if he did do
something wrong I think that they've all
been a little Shady
Democrat and Republican side you know I
really there's no one's perfect no one's
perfect
you know if you want to break it down
real basic the only thing I really have
to go by is how he's affecting me in my
personal life in my community my people
around me and things on the up-and-up
why would I want to bite my nose off to
spite my face are you worried for Donald
Trump not at all
no all that guy's invincible yeah we got
Wildcat in there we've got a guy who's
out there swinging I love it he thinks
like I do you know a survivor
he actually called me for doing a test
on his water do you want me to remove my
shoes okay yeah so four more years
wasn't it I sure the hell hope so I sure
hope so my objective is to build this
business because I can't and sell it in
the about the second year of his next
tenure right where's lease isn't the
only business round here who say they've
really prospered under Trump so to them
the Democrats by going ahead with
impeachment are just trying to ruin the
good times and stop the boon that they
felt in the last three years
Carol raised her four children in Racine
where she's lived for 33 years she's
been glued to the whole impeachment
process so some people say these
hearings have lacked pizzazz but they
haven't had a kind of blockbuster moment
to pull the public in should they have
pizzazz is it very serious yeah I think
it's a very serious process and I
disagree I think there's been several
moments that were very stunning I don't
know I think they're there either you're
open to them or you're not whether
you're listening or you're not you're
not a Trump fan you didn't vote for him
how did you feel the day he was elected
I think to most I think six years so
much yeah what about the people who
we've spoken to who say you know what
Trump has done good things for me my
business is thriving impeachment a
little bit abstract it's not affecting
me I can put food on my table more that
I've been able to in you yeah well I'd
like to talk to who that person is
because I don't think the middle class
is really
you know and he has helped middle class
as a Democrat do you ever wish that they
just left impeachment alone and focused
on beating him I don't think they had a
choice and I think that if you're you
know when you talk about history and you
know what did you do you know when this
happened I think that they can feel like
they they did what they could to hold
him accountable how will you feel as an
American in the world if before
Christmas your president is impeached I
think I would be relieved and sad at the
same time I mean it's not it's a somber
moment the Carroll felt quite unique
because she had a real understanding a
clear understanding of what the whole
impeachment case is actually about what
struck me as well about her as well she
very much in favor of impeachment it's
really with a heavy heart
Americans are patriotic they want to be
proud of their president
pride in America is one of the few
unifying ideas at the moment with wildly
differing interpretations che su and
Ryan a part of Racine's Republican
women's group formed in the face of an
enemy the lack of respect that I have
seen from the Democrats over the last
several years towards this president is
shameful they're treating him
differently and I don't think they've
done that to any other president in the
past just because of who he is and I
don't think it's fair I mean they've
been talking impeachment before it ever
happened
bribery and using military those are
very strong accusations to accuse the
President of the United States that you
do believe that is a serious allegation
absolutely and if it wasn't should be
outright wrong if any one of them in the
judiciary or the intelligence committees
use those words they had better damn
well have documentation to support them
because those are real serious charges
what they would say is they have had
witness upon witness upon witness who
has collaborated their witnesses their
witnesses what's the truth I don't you
know I don't think it goes back to what
I said we don't even care you don't care
what the truth I really don't care what
the truth is about the Ukraine cuz I
really don't I care about what is
happening in my house right now can
Donald Trump survive impeachment yes yes
and when 2020 yes yes hands down do you
have a moment where you think this might
all be true No mm-hmm no not for a
second not for a second are the
Republicans on the right side of history
here yes I think so I think we will be
yeah you you will find that Donald Trump
probably is one of the greatest
presidents that the United States of
America has ever seen to this point in
time
the Democrats have gone such lengths to
present credible witnesses hours of
testimony transcripts but for people
like Sue and her friends it will never
be enough they are with Trump no matter
what the two different Americas are dug
in at Racine's Technical College
impeachment is an entirely different
story I see all these Republicans trying
to get in the way of everything and it's
gonna be a battle it's gonna be a battle
like I figured that way he's just not a
good dude that's what my students say so
I don't know if you can run the country
successfully having all of these hidden
agendas especially when you are against
people of color you are against women
next election is gonna be your first
time voting that's very exciting is this
impeachment thing gonna be in your minds
when you cast that vote I mean it's a
year away yeah it is I think it will
just because there is a lot of stuff to
think about do you think Donald Trump's
on the edge of his seat I almost feel
like he's not I almost feel like he
thinks that he is honestly above the law
and I think that he thinks that is you
know whatever this is you know a show
and I'm gonna get out of this I've
gotten out of everything else so for the
people who despise Trump this whole
impeachment thing is just a continuation
of the scandal the controversy that's
dogged him from the very start they've
had enough but they're not under any
illusion that he's going to be removed
from office and that impeachment will
actually stop him being president
[Music]
for a lot of people impeachment is just
background noise
a dry sideshow to their daily lives
which are more focused on gearing up for
the holiday season you want to talk
about impeachment not at all talk about
impeachment I think yeah yes I do
I say impeachment you say no way bring
it on
differing views still friends what's
going on with your president right now
[Music]
I'd like to see him bounced out on his
pardon me
behind behind do you think it was a
risky move the dunny chance to do this I
do is it paying off we'll find out
[Music]
Wednesday night is League night at the
Racine bowling alley people have worked
hard all day they're here to unwind
they're not obsessing over the latest
from Capitol Hill so Washington is
wrapped up in impeachment
Wisconsin is getting on with life and
something really interesting that people
have been saying to us here is that they
used to be able to talk about politics
when they came out with friends but now
things are so volatile so toxic they
just don't go there unless we ask them
of course how do you feel about trouble
[Music]
your friend has been telling me she
would not cry a river if Trump was
impeached how would you feel if Trump
was impeached for what what do you do I
just I said I'm not even following it I
just think that's the problem less
Americans the average Americans don't
really foul the facts shouldn't Donald
Trump of being America's in tracks we
get a lot of money a lot of countries
and I think if they should be doing we
ask them to do if they want our aid
otherwise if they're gonna help us out
screw you go somewhere else the people
make up their minds making the rift
between us greater I see
families I've seen people not talk to
each other brothers and sisters so the
idea that he pressured a foreign
government to interfering in a u.s.
election for his own political gain you
buy that you buy that case okay Donald
Trump II anti-corruption Crusader was
that what he was trying to do means do
you have a problem with that are you
still friends okay that's good to see
deep breaths
[Music]
like tirana and Lewis America will move
on from this moment each side has
entirely different ideas about what
history will make of it Donald Trump
will most likely be impeached but by
next Christmas he may well be settling
into the White House for a second term
and could have the people of Racine
County Wisconsin
[Music]